night two of jetlag is always the worst
night one when you first get there so
tired you just conk out but on night two
you're rested and so your brain kind of
goes back into its old circadian rhythm
and you end up waking up at 3 in the
morning if you're in Europe and you're
from the United States
[Music]
I'm like this big proponent of like you
can learn any skill on your own and so
people are like well why go to college
and I have a take on this that I want to
talk about because there's a really
important aspect to my story that I
haven't talked about which is the fact
that I went to call it I got a
bachelor's and a master's degree and
those have been fundamental and the work
that they do now and I want to explain
why yeah people are intense er they bike
to work in the snow man if there was
this much snow in DC right now the whole
city would be shut down
we just can't handle it but here it's
like oh it's snowing cool everyone biked
to work I don't want to make it sound
like I just use my parents camcorder and
messed around and then suddenly I got
this great job at Vox and now you make
international documentaries that's not
how it worked first off the video piece
was as you've seen a lot of work and a
lot of time a lot of bad stuff but the
other side of this the International
Relations the journalism piece that is
also a huge body of work let's call
these soft skills and hard skills of the
video the graphic design the motion
graphics all that the soft skills are
the thinking skills the academia stuff
to me this is a key ingredient in the
skill set that allows me to do what I do
today and I want to break down why and
how it effects my work and why it's so
important that I have these soft skills
in my skill set
so what do I mean by soft skills makes
them sound like they're not that great
maybe we should come up with a new term
that isn't hard and soft skills I put
into this video I'm gonna come up with
some new term for hard and soft skills
so stay tuned for that I should talk it
through first soft skills you're - for
known as soft skills soon to be changed
and something else in my mind our skills
that you learn that are not prescribed
in a manual there's no tutorial for soft
skills they are thinking skills they're
how to ask the right questions how to
inquire into society's biggest questions
their skills that that allow you to
critically think about the world and to
understand the world in a better way
hard skills are kind of the opposite
they are skills that allow you to
execute things like programming or
graphic design these aren't skills that
necessarily help you understand the
world but you are able to execute things
and build things and they're technical
they require an understanding of a
technical language that is used to
execute a deliverable or a thing okay so
soft skills are more thinking academic
skills hard skills are more technical
executable building stuff skills
nyan ever since we did that Hong Kong
story on neon lights for borders I just
have this new appreciation for neon and
what's it that's a better term for this
stuff soft skills if you want to tell
stories about the world and you want to
convey information in any form whether
it's explainer stuff or narrative or
journalism or whatever it is you have to
have a broad foundation of soft skills
of critical thinking skills you have to
you don't have to go to school always
for those but if there's anything school
as good at in my opinion it's not the
hard skills it's not the technical stuff
to me that's the stuff you can learn on
your own to me what college is good for
is the soft skills is the critical
thinking that's the thing that like the
professors and the academics of like
figured out how to teach and figure out
how to convey so I'm done talking in
abstract concepts here I'll tell you how
it worked for me
as I've said before I switch to
international relations after a semester
of I've been disillusioned with the film
program and I immediately discovered a
world of discussion and debate and
inquiry there's no right answer in
international relations there is a an
ongoing debate the academics call it a
discourse which is a very wonky academic
word there is an ongoing discourse about
the world how the world works how
society works what's the best policy to
help the world work better and for
people to be more peaceful and no one
agrees and that's great in fact that's
like what soft skills are all about is
that no one agrees on this stuff but
there's a bunch of people out there
inquiring and that's another wonky term
inquiry inquiry inquiring what they're
doing what that basically means is
they're asking questions why is it when
you cut taxes on this certain thing all
of these other things happen as a
response
[Music]
and they study it and have these methods
that they dig into to study it and that
is inquiry and then they write up a
paper and they submit it to a journal
and then all their peers professors from
different universities read this article
and now it's a part of the discourse now
it's a contribution to this ongoing
discussion about how the world works
that is the process of at least the
social science that I studied
international relations political
science and even economic
[Music]
my mind started to change how I saw the
world I didn't see the world as some
sort of I'm looking for the right answer
I started to see everything as a as an
exercise of inquiry what can I ask about
the world that's interesting and then
how would I go about finding the answer
what evidence could I find that would
help me understand this thing better you
do that for four years and you become a
much more nuanced and powerful finger
suddenly you're able to access the
discourse you're able to say oh I'm
interested in tax policy and zoning law
in Hong Kong instead of like trying to
find the Wikipedia article I'm gonna
literally find the person who studies
this and read their academic research
important caveat to all of this I'm not
a school person formal education was
always very difficult for me I'm
diagnosed with dyslexia and ADHD to
neurochemical things that make it really
hard for me to jump through the typical
hoops of reading a bunch of text books
and taking a multiple-choice test and
all the kind of those formal things that
we do in college and in school generally
I just kind of sucked at all ways and so
I struggled in even in college I
struggled even when I was feeling
empowered by this information of inquiry
I still struggled to perform and ended
up not doing super great in college but
to me the textbooks and the kind of
memorizing facts that's not what you're
supposed to learn in college like that's
not what is useful about going to an
institution with a bunch of smart
professors what's useful about that
experience is learning how to think
differently you can learn the facts by
reading a book or going onto Wikipedia
like and the college environment is an
environment of debate and inquiry and so
you're constantly surrounded with these
debates
do you learn to think differently to me
this skill is so important for the work
that I do my job is to go out and to ask
big questions about big international
issues and I will say that my education
primed me to be able to do that tipple
are probably able to develop those
skills on their own in the same way that
you can develop video skills on your own
but to me it's a lot harder it's hard to
find a replacement for the setting when
you're sitting around with your peers
debating and discussing and you have a
professor who's really smart who's
leading the discussion who is helping
push your ideas past where they
currently are that to me is a unique
academic experience that College
provides so the big takeaway from all
this and the thing that I think is
really important to mention is that soft
skills are important arts feels
important together they are incredibly
powerful and that's what I've built a
career off of is blending these soft
skills with hard skills it's a really
powerful combination to have a social
science mix with a hard skill and I
don't think this is gonna change anytime
soon I think hard skills are gonna
become increasingly more valuable and if
you hedge by learning some hard skills
in addition to your soft skills you'll
be in good shape I hope this was helpful
snow on my lens hope this was helpful in
some way having some basis of my
perspective on college and hard skills
and soft skills and the combination of
those skills I didn't come up with a
cool alternative vernacular for hard
skills and soft skills I wish I would
have come with a different term if you
have like an idea of like what's a
better term to describe these two
different buckets of skills that's
better and more descriptive than hard
skill and soft skill I'd love to hear it
all right I'm gonna explore this city as
it wakes up still very early and snowy
and I will see you next time
[Music]